guys i'm just a couple of thousand
pounds away from reaching my target
twenty thousand pounds inshallah
for families in gaza to have clean water
for one year going to an america
america's most racist town with the sign
that says black lives matter let's see
what happens
about 10 minutes i'm gonna be back you
better be [ __ ] gone
okay come back
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum today better care to
your brothers and sisters and dear
friends we're going to be showing the
double standards and the hypocrisy
of the islamophobes in the west and
around the world when it comes to the
issue of freedom of speech
they make it seem like freedom of speech
is something that islam opposes
right they make it seem like muslims are
the only ones
that get angry and antagonized yeah
and especially when provoked so they
make it seem like we muslims
like everyone else if they are
antagonized and provoked
they're just like hey mate it's your
freedom of speech but when it comes to
muslims
we are the only ones that get angry and
upset
why what's so special about us well
we're going to watch a video
and expose the islamophobes further
and how they have double standards and
hypocrisy by supporting
extremist radical christians who
desecrate the quran and they do this
because they realize that islam is
growing they can't intellectually
challenge it
and that shahadas are taking place left
right center
and the only way they can attack is by
insulting
islam like they did um in spain
in cordoba and i encourage everyone to
read the book of cordoba now the video
that we're going to watch right now
brothers and sisters
is a man going to an america america's
most
racist town with the sign that says
black lives matter let's see what
happens
here we go
i want to say after dark man honestly
dude you have balls of steel
because you can get hospitalized by some
guys that want to beat your ass
i've had several old men come out here
look out the window and tell me since
you better go tell that [ __ ] get out
of
here
did you guys hear that did i say that
did any of these people come and say you
know what we in the west
be liberal or not liberal we believe in
your freedom of speech mate
and all he's holding is what black lives
matter
that's all he's not insulting he's not
desecrating anything
all he's saying is black lives matter
matter and that's what he's holding
they're calling him the n word
somebody's telling me if i was you
i wouldn't be here at dark let's carry
on let's see what else happens
i'm putting his middle finger up look
what this guy says about ten minutes i'm
gonna be back you better be [ __ ] gone
okay come back
we matter too you're a white man great
[ __ ] you dumb
are you a marxist communist domestic
terrorist
once you take to chicago or new york is
cold enough before they're shooting
together
explain to me why i couldn't
that [ __ ] don't make [ __ ] here hey all
lives matter not just black
you're the caucasians
i'm tired of seeing this right here is
the biggest hoax there ever was it's
just the next thing to ask
it is irish
in a nutshell all he's done is gone to a
specific area
um which is uncalled for because it's
disturbing the peace no matter how
racist they are
the point is this one sisters is that
this specific individual is going to
an area and is always seen as black
lives matter and
he is being abused so much so people are
telling them don't stay here at dark
and somebody's coming say i'm gonna be
back in 10 minutes you better not be
here
now what is the point here that i'm
trying to make the point here is doesn't
justify anybody attacking anyone
physically
the point here to be made is that this
is not exclusive to muslims
because it's been made out to seem like
oh whenever we insult muslims or insult
you know we don't um we don't believe in
blasphemy laws freedom of speech yeah
well if that's the case why doesn't
these people
even if you go to the liberals yeah
we're gonna have many videos that we're
gonna be reacting to
different communities reacting in a very
similar way
this shows to us that it is human nature
and what that means is there's a lot of
people are gonna verbalize like for
example when
someone insults islam i just ignore them
i don't give my time to them
and i believe they're aiding islam
because what they're doing just shows
how hateful they are
and anyone that is fair and
in the middle not on anyone's side when
they see that they're not going to agree
with that
so i don't i don't agree with that but
there are people within our muslim
community
that might take different action the
same with the black community the jewish
community the gay community the the
lgbt community um the black community
the turkish community the kurdish
committee the asian community all of
them
there are different people that are
going to react to being provoked in
different ways
some people will ignore some people say
i'm better than that some people punch
you in the face and some will go
to levels of even taking your life the
point here
is the following that no matter who you
go to
the same results will exist but why is
it
that islam and muslims are made to seem
like they are the only ones
that have this issue the whole world is
okay with freedom of speech
except muslim this is bs the reason is
is because the only case study
that's been used is against muslims that
is the reason why
we're going to explore the psychology
behind human beings while we go to
different communities
and ask them going to the black
community and saying if we was to come
and use the n-word here what would
happen to us if you go to the jewish
community and say
if i was to come here and hold the
banner that says holocaust didn't happen
and we love hitler what would happen if
we went to
a nationalist area let's say up north
and
had a picture of churchill and someone
pooing on his head or the british flag
and i was like desecrating it what do
you think would happen to me do you
think these british people these
flipping islamophobe scums would come
and say ali
you know i despise what you say but i
would defend your right to say it like
and um a philosopher said a couple of
them i forget all their names
the point is this guys they are going to
come and kill me
forget all of that forget put religion
to a side football england
imagine i was there and i was i had an
italian shirt i just walked past them
what do you think what happened to me
so why is it that when muslims are upset
and are provoked so much so that
um people insult back or are harsh
or for example besides attacking that's
that's i don't mean there's any
reason to do that why is it that even if
that happens
it's muslim and islam to blame that is
hypocrisy we're going to show i hope you
guys enjoyed this video
till next time salaam alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh